bonjour claire s'écaille bienvenus vous
êtes chercheuse au cnrs spécialiste des
médias bonjour claire s'écaille bonjour
soyez la bienvenue vous êtes historienne
des médias le document qui résume votre
étude est consultable alors à la fois
sur le blog de votre laboratoire de
recherche mais aussi on l'a mis à
disposition de nos auditeurs sur la page
de l'instant même sur le site france
inter point fr un moratoire alors voilà
c'est magnifique alors
philippot chevrolet qui nous a rejoint
et florian si nicky de spécialiste de la
communication politique merci d'être là
vous avez vous dire vraiment ce que vous
en pensez moi je vais vous dire quand il
se passe des trucs comme ça je suis
heureux je vais vous dire je pense qu'il
ya c'est incroyable parce que
aujourd'hui je pense que personne ne s'y
attendait et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
ces 8es pour moi le la chaîne qui fait
aussi beaucoup parler au niveau
politique et s'y attendait pas surtout
sur nos démissions et donc qu'on fasse
une étude comme ça pour moi c'est ça
c'est flatteur je voulais le dire à
claire s'écaille donc merci m de nous
regarder pendant deux censeurs est la
plus regardée des missions que moi
est ce qui ressort de l enquête alors
d'abord il ya deux choses qui ressort
des enquêtes alors d'abord elle dit on
est pro zemmour on est plus après le
dîner en fait on est pro mac ou et après
on est pro rien on est haute mais vous
allez voir alors ce sont dans les têtes
donc ces voix là ne pas tout si moore
tout le temps écouter ce que disent et
claire s'écaille ce matin sur france
inter alors elle a réussi à se faire
inviter par tout ça car ils ont fait une
demi heure là dessus ce matin et ils
sont première à d'autres ans on est
complet comme quoi
écoutez donc 53 % du temps d'antenne
politique du talk show consacré à la
hausse aux différentes sphères de
l'extrême droite avec un grand gagnant
là dedans eric zemmour oui alors c'est
le premier enseignement et je dois dire
que ça m'a quand même assez surpris
quand j'ai commencé à sortir mes
premiers résultats au fil des semaines
ce set cette place majoritaire qu'à
l'extrême droite dans cette émission là
moi qui n'avais pas beaucoup regardé
cette émission de la veille avant de me
lancer dans ce terrain ça me paraissait
peut-être pas si évident que ça d'y
répondre aussi affirmativement et les
ordres de grandeurs m'ont surpris et
encore plus je dois dire là l' approche
plus qualitative encore alors donc tout
le monde a repris derrière voila voila
hanouna marchepied d'eric zemmour 53 %
du temps politique et compte consacrer à
l'extrême droite c'est faux puisque
c'est sans contredit scan a beaucoup qui
les 53 % du temps d'antenne de tpm pic
alors que en fait le temps d'antenne
politique qui s'est toujours selon terre
ces cas ils représentent que 17% de
l'émission donc en fait c'est représente
que 8,5 pour cent de l'émission globale
donc voilà deux eric zemmour on va pas
se mentir
c'est toujours un carton d'audience mais
on va pas regarder en étant direct chez
laurent ruquier 1116 mille c'était le
record avant un des records d'audience
débat mélenchon zemmour 3,8 millions
interview d'eric zemmour le 20 heures de
tf1 7,3 millions c'est dans l'air ça a
très bien marché sur france 5 aussi face
à bfm huit cent vingt mille c'est leur
corps aussi donc nous voilà alors ce
qu'elle dit claire c'est qu'elle sait
qu'elle ne s'occupe pas des autres mais
c'est vrai que nous forcément où on
parle d'eric zemmour pourquoi parce que
eric zemmour va pas se mentir c'est mine
aujourd'hui qui fait le plus parler de
lui géraldine d'abord moi je trouve que
1 d'abord c'est gratifiant et valorisant
qui est une chercheuse du cnrs qui voit
on regarde comme objet télévisuel
incroyable phénomène a commencé des jeux
comme un fou après là où je trouve qu'il
ya un vrai problème c'est que
effectivement elle est du côté de la
bien-pensance ou suite france inter là
où ça parle tous mais que dans un sens
elle devrait venir elle devrait se
confronter au réel elles devraient venir
ici nous expliquer pourquoi son étude
conclut ça parce que ce serait vraiment
intéressant y aurait un vrai débat gelés
et moi je pense que là où elle a tort
aussi c'est le canton va les
préoccupations des français aujourd'hui
en pouvoir d'achat pouvoir d'achat c'est
40 % la préoccupation des français en
deux c'est l'immigration et en 3 c'est
la sécurité et si on cumule la sécurité
d'immigration on peut le déplorer on
peut trouver que c'est catastrophique
mais il trouve que c'est en fait ça fait
45 % c'est la préoccupation des français
souhaitent que les français saluent ça
lui plaît pas mais c'est la
préoccupation des ford est donc en fait
il ya un vrai mais moi mais moi je ne
veux parler des préoccupations le
chômage en veux pas clair s'écaille en
fait ce que claire sécail on le fait
cette étude elle donne les chiffres
voilà après ces chiffres ils sont pas
bons je vais vous dire pourquoi dans un
instant ce qu'on l'a vu hier c'est la
france a soumis ce qui est le plus
représenté dans mes émissions et je vous
montrerai thaler d'ailleurs à l'avouer
ce matin chez sonia devillers mais si
c'était yannick jadot ou anne hidalgo
qui faisait parler d'elle on aurait fait
53 pour son antenne sur un 10 2 philippe
moreau chevrolet donc au début ça c'est
bon pour moi c c c et c c'est le graal
c'est génial comment j'avais fait une bd
le président je suis dans le rapport du
cnrs aussi bah oui parce qu'on avait
parlé en rêver dit en gros que c'était
vous intéresser à la politique mais je
pense qu'ils comprennent pas la démarche
que vous n'êtes pas dans la télé vous
êtes dans l'engagement c'est à vous
regarder ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux vous êtes branché là dessus et
vous êtes le seul à avoir invité les
gilet jaune en plateau en télé au début
parce que vous essayez de voir ce qui se
passe en fait dans les tendances
associées de voir aussi le temps
d'antenne gilet jaune année dernière
alors moi je suis sur les plateaux en
permanence jeu pour parler politique et
je suis de plus en plus entouré de gens
qui sont des partisans d'eric zemmour
donc il se passe un truc qui est
dynamique électorale dynamique politique
laissez pas vous qui l'avez créer cette
dynamique parcours vous avez été branché
dessus avant les autres parce que vous
avez 7 vous allez chercher sur les
réseaux des autres que les autres
trouvent pas mais c'est pas de la télé
vous faites c'est de l'engagement et
mais pourquoi les avait joués avait même
genre que ceux qui regardent la télé
habituellement les autres journalistes
reprennent tous en plus des chiffres pas
soit un peu fou un peu bizarre florian
n'est pas là dessus mais d'abord parce
que vous faites vendre six mois j'étais
le propriétaire d'un média je passerais
mon temps à dire du mal de vous cyril la
preuve je pense que l'humanité ne s'est
jamais aussi bien vendus aujourd'hui
ensuite il ya deux points qui me
paraissent extrêmement important d'abord
on vous a reproché de trop recevoir les
gilets jaunes ensuite on vous a trop en
faire on vous a reproché de trop
recevoir les ministres du gouvernement
macro nous accuser de faire la
propagande de ce gouvernement et du
président de république et ensuite on
vous reproche aujourd'hui d'avoir pointé
aussi de pleurer d'inviter aussi des
femmes voilées aussi sur le plateau
avant c'était voilà et il a que des
lames et voilà exactement donc voilà on
a chaque fois où on fait un truc voilà
on nous le reproche en fait pourquoi
parce qu'on vous reproche d'être le
reflet des préoccupations des français
et que même point extrêmement important
et elle utilise sa casquette de
chercheur du cnrs pour dévoiler ou
donner les leçons un certain nombre
d'animateurs télévisé sur ces mêmes
plateaux il faut dire que c'est d'abord
une militante politique elle est plus
militante politique que chercheuse
d'ailleurs il suffit de taper son nom
sur internet pour voir quelles à publier
des tribunes d'une violence absolue
notamment contre nicolas sarkozy et je
crois que il faudrait par transparence
et dire quels sont ses propres
engagements et sa peau que l'on
comprenne mieux quelles sont les
conclusions de l'étude